All right. Hello everyone. How are you
guys doing? Hope you guys are having a
wonderful day. Today we're here with
another video and today's video will be
on calculating how much money you can
expect to make per hour doing medium
clues. Now, the other day I was thinking
about this and we have resources to
actually be able to find this. So, I
thought it'd be something very
interesting and I think it's a lot more
profitable than most people think. So,
with that said, let's go ahead and get
on into it. So, now over on RS Buddies
website, they have this really cool tool
that has tracked all of the clue scrolls
that have been done on their client,
which is actually really incredible. As
you guys can see with medium clues, they
have 3.7 million track. And they also
have the total profit coming in about
550 bill, which is absolutely insane to
even think about those numbers when you
compare it to what I mean you expect to
see on a day-to-day. But as you guys can
see, the average for a medium clue
scroll comes out to around 146k. Now,
there are some other stats I can go
ahead and show you guys down here. Now,
if we go ahead and look, uh, at mediums,
you're really only looking for ranger
boots. I mean, some other stuff you're
going to get actually will have value,
such as pages and whatnot, but for the
most part, this is what we're looking
at. So, as you guys can see, we have
14.7,000 ranger boots. Now, when you go
ahead and compare that to the amount of
clues done, while it while the amount of
clues does seem to be just
extraordinarily higher, it actually is a
1 in 215 chance per clue based on the
stats that OSD has for their website.
So, with those stats, we can assume you
can make around 145k per medium clue
that you do on average. Now, some people
will get more lucky and get more ranger
boots cuz ranger boots are where you're
going to make a majority of this money.
I think your average for a medium clue
without getting ranger boots is more
around 50kish and with ranger boots it
hops up to 145k. But even at 145k to
146k, it's still the exact same average
as hard clues, which is incredible. I
just I can't even wrap my mind around
that. That's just ridiculous that it's
so badly balanced. But anyways, now that
we know that, I guess we can go and look
at one of my previous videos where I
compared what the best method was to go
ahead and get medium clues. So, as you
guys can see in this video, basically,
eclectics are the best way to go ahead
and get medium clues by far. If you guys
want to watch that comparison video,
link will be in the description down
below if you want to decide that for
yourself. But if you just want to trust
me, just go ahead and do that.
Basically, the price right now is 3.2K.
So, if you're going to do 25, which is
the average for a medium clue, you're
going to come in at 80k cost. Now, the
cost of a clue here is
37.5K. However, when you consider the
fact that now the price has gone up a
little bit, it's now moved up to about
42k per clue. However, even as much as a
couple weeks ago, eclectics were 2K,
just barely above 2K. So, I mean, this
could have been pretty much like almost
free mediums, but not a lot of people
took advantage of it. So now taking 146k
which you can expect for a medium clue
and subtracting 42k from that you can
expect a net profit of 104k per clue on
average. So what you need to take into
account now is how long it's going to
take you to do a medium clue on average.
Now this is obviously going to vary
account to account based on what things
you have unlocked within the game to
make teleporting easier and whatnot. But
we will go to the clue scroll god for
this information. All right. So I tried
contacting Kum on Twitter. However, I am
not that popular yet. So, I was not able
to get a response. However, I looked
through some of his comment sections and
I found someone that asked the same
question. So, basically, he asked, "On
average, how long does a medium clue
take you?" And Karum said, "On average 3
to 5 minutes, depending on how far away
each step is from each other." Now, this
obviously is with the best times in the
game. Uh, some people that were in the
comments also said that they could
average around 12 clues per hour, some
saying up to 15, but for the average
here, we're going to go ahead and take
his high average of 5 minutes. This may
be actually too high considering a lot
of the medium clues are like really easy
to get to and you don't need that many
hard teleports unlocked. But for the
sake of the video, I'm going to
overestimate the amount of time that it
would probably take you per medium clue
and say 5 minutes. So basically what
this means is that if you are able to
average 5minute clues, you can expect to
make upwards of 1.2 mil per hour on
average. Now that's absolutely insane
considering medium clues are kind of
just a fun thing to do within the game.
They're just really enjoyable to do
because you know it's not really a
grind. It's not a constant thing. I I I
mean, I'd imagine once you get up to the
point where Kum's taking it and you're
doing 20,000, I'm sure it feels like a
grind, but for me, I've done two to 300
and I still feel just as fresh as at the
beginning. It's still fun. It's still
enjoyable. And to be able to make 1.2
mil per hour, you know, not even with
the best teleports, that's pretty
insane. He says he averages 3 to 5
minute clues. And if we take that,
that's, you know, a 4-minute clue. 15 an
hour comes in at about 1.5 to 1.6 mil.
So, I mean really this is a decent
money-making method if you consider that
on average that's what you should be
making. Now, I know some people may
crush it and say, "Uh, RNG dependent
money-making methods aren't good." I
mean, that's not true at all. They're
good for some people and bad for others.
You know, it works out and in the end it
evens out. So, you know, maybe luck
might not be on your side, but this is a
really good money-making method and it's
something I would, you know, encourage
people to do as it I find it enjoyable
and you make really good money. So,
hopefully you guys enjoy the video. If
you guys did, make sure to leave a like.
If there's anything you guys want to see
from me in the future, make sure to
comment that down below. Following up
this video, I may make a medium clue
hunting guide. If you guys want me to go
ahead and make that, basically just
showing off the inventory and the best
ways to get to each clue. If you guys
want to see that, let me know down below
with a like and a comment. Uh, subscribe
to the channel if you enjoy the content.
Twitch and Twitter in the description
down below. And we have the clan chat
large exp. Make sure to hit that up. I'm
always in there because I'm always
[__] playing. But with that said,
hopefully you guys have a wonderful day.
It
[Music]